how do you think the actions of your
team in the last 72 hours have just sort
of changed the atmosphere around here
from it from a team moms calling on
someone is that your phone I didn't mean
to blow your wad but it's a cream I was
calling you yeah I think our management
has sent a message we're trying to get
better but I don't buy that oh now now
you're now that we make a deal any one
of those guys other than handy handy is
it going or not a center but says he can
go to center or wing yeah but I mrs.
Reid mrs. Reid hi this is John
Tortorella I'm in the middle of a press
conference here in your your no that's
okay I'd rather talk to you than your
husband I mean your son and so I'll be
done in about five my scene you call a
few times so it's rude it's rude if yeah
he's Drude of him not to call you back
but he's busy right now it's nice
talking to you okay have a nice day
where was I what